- I do care, I care a lot.
And that's why I fight back.
As long as I'm alive
there'll be more to say.
Just finding out what
people's favorite thing is,
what they're reacting to.
Now my anger is very focused.
I would like to leave a footprint.
I think it's important to try everything.
♫ Ohhhhhhhh ohhhhhhh yeah yeah
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability
to do something special
that can change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from
three-time Grammy Award winner
Pink and my take on her
top ten rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(gentle music)
- You've been very outspoken and I saw
you with your daughter the VMAs.
I thought it was it was just amazing.
- [Pink] There's just always
so much work to be done
and I talk about these things
because I've lived them,
I've been through.
There hasn't been a day that has gone by
that someone hasn't said
something nasty about me.
And it's not that it doesn't hurt me
or that I'm invincible
or that I don't care.
I do care, I care a lot.
And that's why I fight back.
♫ Na na na na na na na
♫ I want to start a fight
- [Woman] What you feel is kind of the
next step for you and your career
when you've already achieved so much?
- I think I would like
to be a country singer.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- No, I don't know.
(laughs)
I
still to this day
after all of that nonsense,
I still feel like I have
so much to prove to people.
People still don't get it.
I'm always going to feel like
a really popular underdog.
People to this day still
go, wow, you can sing.
And it's been like 13
years of just singing.
So there will always
be as long as I'm alive
there will be more to say, I think.
I don't know what that is exactly but as
long as my body can keep up with my mind
then I'll be all right.
My favorite part about
giving my baby not my Willow,
but my baby, my other
baby, my album away is
just waiting for the feedback you know
from the fans on the website.
And just from friends
and different people.
Well most of my friends I have to like
give them an album and then let them know
I put it out because
they don't really care.
But just finding out what people's
favorite thing is, what
they're reacting to.
And what the feedback is the part.
- Let me ask you something
as somebody who's a who makes
their living as a performer, as an artist,
as a as a singer, as a songwriter
and all that, what do you want to get out
of this whole thing?
Like, what do you want out of this?
- Well I kind of already did all the
things I said I was going to
do when I was a little girl.
Be famous, piss people off.
(laughing)
- You must have been a real treat at 12.
You would have been a real.
- Now, I used to be angry at the world.
Now my anger is very focused.
I would like to leave a footprint and
and if I can help inspire
other people to be individuals and stand
up for what they believe
in and be who they are
then I did my job.
And sometimes inspiration is is what is
the most important thing is what we need
to get moving, and our
country needs to get moving.
I think the reason why
I have such an authentic
relationship with I don't
even like the word fans,
but with people
is because I am
being honest and I am being vulnerable
and I am talking about
real life and my real life
and kind of wearing all my flaws visibly.
So it's it's helped me
feel less alone.
- Did you start working
with, for a little time,
with this band called Basic
Instinct and choice right?
- Yeah.
- What could it be like the
biggest lesson of that time?
- I'm a chameleon, I
think it's important to
I mean I trained
classically, I sang in gospel
in all black churches
and I had a punk band.
I think it's important to try everything.
And I don't, I mean I play drums
but my voice is my instrument.
So it's important to use it
in every way that you can
to get better you know.
And don't be narrow-minded and that's what
being indifferent I mean Basic Instinct
I was a token white girl.
And choice was this white R&B
group and you know,
it's just a lot of different things
it was really good for my resume.
The way that you walk on
that stage is the outcome
you're going to get.
I've had shows back-to-back
shows in the same place,
same lineup, almost
basically the same audience.
And the first night I've
walked on feeling insecure
and I've had the worst show of my life
and it's all in here.
And then the second day I'm like,
well screw that I don't
want to do that again.
What's the worst that can happen
it can't be worse than that.
And I go on not caring as much
and I have the best show of my life.
So it's just a it's a head game.
So you kind of just, my
dad tells me to throw my
head back spit in the wind
and show them what I got,
so that's what I do.
I have always said that pain
and frustration and anger
sadness,
it's all just motivation to write.
I think when I'm happy I'm useless.
I mean I just think the best work comes
from heartbreak or devastation or loss
or insanity.
♫ Have you ever
♫ Held your breath
♫ Ask yourself
♫ (Mumbling)
(cheering)
♫ Tonight
- You all saw Pink's performance
at the Grammys, right.
(applause)
Oh my goodness.
I mean literally I was
just saying to the audience
I had to get closer to my
TV to see what was actually
happening that was a jaw-dropping
ceiling hanging almost naked ripped
bodies situation.
(laughing)
All I can say is, "Wowie kazowie."
Everybody all over the world the next day
was like, "Did you see that?
- Yeah.
- "Did you see that?"
- It was fun I was a good night for me.
- Was it a good night?
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- That was one of my
first questions to you
because all of us have in our lives
you know momentous occasions like a
moment of your life that one of the
greatest moments of your life.
So you think that will always be?
- I think so, I think so, for me
it was it was when everyone
stood up at the end
that came down just
I know my silks and I
was working it and I.
(laughing)
And then I let the silks
go and everyone stood
up and I went from super
graceful to like je.
(laughing)
Hi, hello.
- It felt transcendent.
It felt like taking us out of something
more than just the music
but into the music.
- And I wanted to get all
the famous people wet.
(laughing)
- I remember seeing
Pink at Brixton Academy
and I was it was Misunderstood record
so I was about 13 or 14.
And I'd never heard live like
being in the in the room
of someone I'd never heard
someone sing like that live.
Do you know what I mean?
Because I was in before that
I was into the Spice Girls
and stuff like that, and
they can't sing obviously.
You know, I know that now.
I remember sort of feeling
like I was in a wind tunnel
and her voice just hitting
me and I mean I was just
it was incredible I mean it was
beyond anything.
And that record is incredible anyway.
But it was my first
experience of like thinking
(bleeped) I mean (bleeped)
I mean, live you know.
Because I you know the
singers before that was like
James and I've never seen them live.
- [Man] I was at the Grammys
in 2010 when Pink did
this stunning rendition of
her ballad Glitter In The Air.
The performance was one of
the most physically courageous
and beautiful things
that I've ever witnessed.
But there is this one moment when she was
lowered into the water
and then lifted back up
out of the whole audience
and she's really like just
gushing water all over
these suddenly scrambling uber serious
VIPs down below.
And I remember watching
this and I'm thinking
that this is the most badass
punk-rock thing that
I've ever seen in music.
♫ You're so mean
♫ When you talk
♫ About yourself
♫ You were wrong
♫ Change the voices
♫ In your head
♫ Make them like you instead
♫ So complicated
♫ Look how we are making
♫ Filled with so much hatred
♫ Such a tired game
♫ It's enough I've done all
♫ I can think of
♫ Chased down all my demons
♫ I've seen you do the same
♫ Oh whoa
♫ Pretty pretty please
♫ Don't you ever ever feel
♫ Like you're less than
♫ Less than perfect
♫ Pretty pretty please
♫ Don't you ever ever feel
♫ Like you're nothing
♫ You are perfect
♫ The whole world scared
so I swallow the fear
♫ The only thing I should be
drinking is an ice-cold beer
♫ The pool in line we try try try
♫ We try so hard wasting my time
♫ Looking for the critics
cause they're everywhere
♫ They don't like my jeans
they don't get my hair
♫ Exchanged ourselves
we do it all the time
♫ Why do I do that
♫ Why do we do that
♫ Why do I
♫ Yeah-eah-eah-eah
♫ Yes
♫ You're perfect
♫ Oh you're perfect
♫ To me
♫ Yeah
♫ Oh whoa
♫ Ohhhhhhh
♫ Yeah yeah yeah
♫ Pretty pretty please
♫ Don't you ever ever feel
♫ Like you're nothing
♫ You are perfect
♫ To me
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Mr.
Lukas DiSparrow asked me to.
If there's someone you'd like to vote on
for the next top ten check out the link
in the description and
go and have your say.
Finally you want to give a
quick shout to Stephanie Noel.
Stephanie thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and tweeting about it.
I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- I'm always trying to be better whether
it's performance or songwriting.
I think vocally I'm a lot better
because I don't smoke anymore.
So I'm just trying to not
repeat myself and try to evolve
and try to just
get better.
Find a quiet inner
strength and hold on to it.
Life can be fabulous if you stick it out.
And I know that seems impossible sometimes
when you're young but I was just there.
I feel like yesterday I
was 13 hating my life,
contemplating suicide
and I found a passion and a hobby.
And I pursued it with blinders
and anyone that didn't like it
could kiss my entire ass.
(cheering)
And they still can.
So take my strength, take my heart,
take everyone in here's strength
and just keep the fight alive, keep going.